primeros detenidos por el asesinato del
fiscal paraguayo marcelo pecci cinco
personas fueron detenidas en colombia
por estar presuntamente implicadas
cuatro de los arrestados son de
nacionalidad colombiana y uno es
venezolano en una operación de trabajo
compartido por parte de la policía
nacional de colombia la fiscalía general
de la nación de colombia y también con
la colaboración de las autoridades
paraguayas hemos capturado a todos los
presuntos involucrados
incluyendo al autor material del
asesinato el fiscal marcelo pecci fiscal
del paraguay
pezzi fue asesinado a tiros el pasado 10
de mayo musicar yo le disparó desde una
moto acuática durante su luna de miel en
las playas de la isla de barú cerca a la
costera cartagena en colombia el
presidente paraguayo le agradeció a su
homólogo colombiano por las capturas y
dijo que espera que las investigaciones
terminen en la judicialización de los
responsables
que se profundiza en los trabajos de
inteligencia para que los culpables
paguen ante la justicia el derecho tan
trágico el resultado del fuerte
compromiso en la lucha contra el crimen
organizado pezzi investigaba en su país
casos de narcotráfico crimen organizado
el lavado de activos y financiamiento
del terrorismo
investigó a los grupos criminales de
origen brasileño primer comando capital
y comando vermelho además de lavadores
de dinero libaneses de la triple
frontera con brasil y argentina también
estuvo a cargo del caso del asesinato de
la hija del ex presidente paraguayo raúl
cubas y el enjuiciamiento en 2020 del
astro retirado del fútbol brasileño
ronaldinho detenido en asunción por
falsificación de pasaporte paraguayo